حليف اخر خي باظنك لجدار اوغلو الدول
الغربيه فعكس بقيه المترشحين لرئاسه الدول
لم يتلقى اي دعوه للزياره او رساله دعم
علانيه رغم انه اختار صفه بعيدا عن روسيا
ومعسكرها ورغم توتر علاقات اردوغان مع
اوروبا على خلفيه ازمته مع اليونان ومع
الناتو ومعارضته في وقت ما انضمام السويد
ومن قبلها فنلندا جعلت الغرب لا يخفي
رغبته في رؤيه رئيس تركيا جديد الا ان
الدول الغربيه رفضت تقديم دعم واضح لكليش
دار اولو هي مخاطر رهان خاسر او ربما بسبب
ذهاب المترشح المعارض بعيدا حين اعطى
وعودا انتخابيه اوروبيه دون موافقه
بروكسيل دخول اوروبا دون تاشيره اضافه
لكسر اتفاقيه اللجوء التي تجمع انقره
ببروكسيل اوروبا لا ترغب في رؤيه ملايين
المهاجرين على الحدود مره اخرى بالطبع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات